hi Bill my name is Shire I am eight
years old my question is how did you
come up with the idea for the light sail
I love you that's a great question so
wasn't really my idea Shia people who
lived before me people as who are
astronomers and physicists discovered
that light even though it has no mass
has a tiny tiny bit of momentum just
while you're sitting there in a room
with what the lights on when you're out
in the Sun there's a just a tiny tiny
push on you because it's pure energy so
when it strikes something it imparts
some energy to it gives the energy a
little push people over just about a
century ago realized if you had a
spacecraft in space of low enough mass
that wouldn't weigh very much on earth
and it was big enough it would get a
push and so my old professor Carl Sagan
was a big advocate of this making of
solar sail as its called
to catch up with comet Holly what you
may sometimes here is called Halley's
Comet and that mission got canceled that
spaceship got canceled for other NASA
projects but now at the planetary site
which he started Carl Sagan started with
the head of the Jet Propulsion lab Bruce
Murray and Lew Friedman who was an
engineer at Jet Propulsion lab out in
California they worked on that Comet
Holly mission and they held it in their
hearts they wanted this thing to fly and
now I have become the CEO of the
Planetary Society started by those three
guys and now 39 years after Carl Sagan
presented this idea to the world we are
flying a much more modest nevertheless
when you look at it it looks very much
the same light sail spacecraft it would
have the capability here's our patch our
mission patch it would have the
capability to take you to the moon to
Mars to asteroids at a very low cost
which is a big problem you know and
anything is how much it costs that is a
great question show I hope you follow
the mission we're in space right now as
I talk and in the next few weeks after
we spread out from other
spacecraft other spacecraft we will
deploy our sails extend our shiny sails
and see if it works by the way if the
sails were black the light would hit it
and give it a push but because they're
shiny the light hits it and bounces off
and that's mathematically exactly twice
the push so Shia that's math and I want
you to get good at it
thanks for the question